débuter notre rayon de commission et
nous remercions le ministre en charge de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires de sa présence
monsieur Christ Béchu je rappelle à tout
le monde que notre audition est
retransmise sur le site internet
du Sénat merci et
dans quelques instants je vais laisser
la parole au ministre après simplement
avoir rappelé que nous sommes dans le
cadre des auditions liées à l'étude du
budget et notamment sur le point
particulier des collectivités locales
dont le rapporteur
est Monsieur Loïc Hervé je ne sais pas
si nos collègues éventuellement de la
commission des finances sont là mais je
ne les vois pas en tous les cas si nous
rejoignent dans les accueillera bien
volontiers pour évoquer avec nous
évidemment le budget des collectivités
territoriales les relations avec l'État
et singulièrement les difficultés de ces
premières collées de ces collectivités
dans le contexte de crise que nous
connaissons actuellement
mais sans occuper plus longtemps la
parole je vais vous laisser la parole
monsieur le ministre pour la
présentation de votre budget et puis
sans doute après monsieur le kervé aura
des questions et puis naturellement les
collègues auront des questions
merci en tous les cas de votre présence
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président
buffet monsieur le
rapporteur Loïc Hervé je salue les
sénatrices et les sénateurs qui
on décide de prendre un peu de leur
temps pour
donner le privilège de pouvoir répondre
à leurs questions et je vais m'efforcer
peut-être du coup d'une introduction
relativement brève de sujets que vous
connaissez pour laisser le plus de temps
possible à l'échange parce que vous lire
à haute voix même de manière commentée
ce qui a dans mon budget manque
d'intérêt
je voudrais avant toute chose peut-être
en quelques instants quand même
répondre à vos propos monsieur le
Président
sur la situation dans laquelle nous
trouvons
le budget de l'État
on le conçoit
au moment de l'été et le dernier
événement en date à ce moment là était
la publication d'un rapport de la Cour
des comptes qui fait qu'avec des effets
de décalage successifs l'analyse par les
magistrats de la situation financière
des collectivités ne se faisait non pas
sur la situation au mois de juillet mais
sur la situation en début d'année et sur
les estimations des contes
administratifs
avec cette petite difficulté c'est qu'on
sait donc basé sur une photographie pour
déterminer ce qui était la bonne santé
des collectivités territoriales là où
au-delà de la photo qui pouvait être et
qui traduisait le fait que sur cinq ans
globalement il y avait une amélioration
de la santé des collectivités
territoriales il y avait un film dont la
tendance n'était pas exactement celle-là
avec une inflation qui s'est qui était
déjà présente au titre de l'année 2021
mais qui a changé de nature et d'ampleur
à partir du 24 février et de l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie
et cette situation elle a amené
d'abord dans le cadre de la loi de
finances rectificative les sénateurs
apportés un dispositif de filet de
sécurité et là ensuite amené le
gouvernement lui-même à remanier à
amender ce qui était sa copie et à
l'heure où je vous parle il reste des
sujets sur lesquels dans le cadre de la
discussion parlementaire et budgétaire
qui va s'ouvrir il n'y a pas douter des
sujets sur lequel la co-construction
doit se poursuivre
les quelques éléments qui sont marquants
et je me contenterai de les présenter
c'est pour la première fois depuis 13
ans une enveloppe de DGF qui non
seulement de baisse pas non seulement
n'est pas stable mais qui réaugmente à
hauteur de 320 millions
c'est la création d'un fond vert qui est
bien une nouveauté budgétaire et qui ne
correspond pas à du recyclage d'argent
ancien même s'il y a une légère baisse
des autorisations d'engagement liées à
la fin du plan de relance et de crédit
qui avait été mis dans le cadre de
Marseille en grand le solde est très
largement positif après de milliards
d'euros quand on retire ces éléments
conjoncturels et que nous les comparons
se font il a été porté à 2 milliards
alors qu'il était un milliard et demi et
il a la volonté d'être extrêmement
souple et de ne pas reposer sur un
dispositif d'appel à projet ou d'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt qui rendrait son
usage trop complexe pour que ce soit un
appui financier réel et concret au
collectivité dès l'année 2023 enfin
il y a face des prix de l'énergie la
stratégie que nous ajustons nous
l'ajustons dans un contexte où ces prix
sont mouvants dans un contexte ou une
partie des discussions se passent avec
nos partenaires européens sur la réforme
du marché de l'électricité et où pour
faire les choses de manière simple la
façon la plus efficace et la plus
vertueuse sur le plan des finances
publiques c'est d'abord d'obtenir des
baisses de prix avant de regarder la
hauteur des boucliers des compensations
ou des amortisseurs ou des filets de
sécurité que nous devons mettre en place
dans ce contexte un nouveau dispositif
de plutôt dispositif où sont présentés
et sont entrés dans l'atmosphère un qui
est un amortisseur sur lequel si vous le
souhaitez je reviendrai et l'autre qui
est un filet de sécurité qui en première
lecture sauf pour des spécialistes de
finances publiques
peut sembler un peu complexe quand on
voit les successions de haie qui
permettent d'en déterminer le montant
mais qui quand on regarde ce qui est son
efficacité le fait qu'il ne soit pas
réservé uniquement au prix de
l'électricité permet je le pense très
sincèrement de répondre de manière
efficace à une partie des surcoûts
significatifs qui existent enfin je ne
doute pas que vous m'interrogerez sur
l'article 23 tel qu'il a été réintroduit
et peut-être dans un contexte où
j'aurais un peu plus de temps à la fois
pour vous répondre et pour développer ma
pensée que ce qui est possible dans un
format de 120 secondes dans un hémicycle
animé un mercredi après-midi entre 15h
et 16 heures
merci Monsieur Hervé
merci monsieur le Président et je saisis
la balle au bon tendue par Monsieur le
Ministre à balle ou moi je reprends la
balle pour évidemment commencer mes
questions par cette question de
l'article 23 et la poursuite de la de
l'échange que vous avez eu avec notre
collègue Christine Labarde tout à
l'heure dans la musique
d'abord sur un plan philosophique je ne
suis pas certain que les contrats de
Cahors et laisser un aussi bon souvenir
parmi nos collègues élus notamment les
présidents d'exécutifs des collectivités
territoriales mais aussi parmi les
parlementaires certains en particulier
dans la relation qui peut être celle qui
existe entre l'État
et les collectivités territoriales dans
notamment les exigences budgétaires qui
sont respectivement les leurs y compris
sur le fait que mais c'est un
une facilité oratoire que de le dire
mais que nous ne sommes pas soumis
d'emblée aux mêmes obligations en termes
d'équilibre budgétaire quand nous sommes
à votre place monsieur le ministre ou
quand nous sommes à la place des élus
qui mèrent président sont en charge des
budgets des grandes collectivités
territoriales et donc
après que le Parlement a supprimé à
l'Assemblée puis au Sénat cette idée de
contrat de confiance
la dimension publicitaire qu'on peut
reconnaître pour un grand groupe
d'électroménager
honnêtement
des contrats dont l'essentiel des close
sur léonine et qui finalement ne sont
pas des contrats je dis sous le contrôle
des collègues Gatel et Darnaud qui ont
eu l'occasion à moultre reprise
d'évoquer ces sujets dans leurs
différents travaux mais est-ce qu'on
peut est-ce qu'on doit pour satisfaire
des exigences européennes
absolument
mettre le licol autour du cou des
collectivités locales à ce point de
recréer et de remettre dans le projet de
loi de finance ce type de dispositif
je pense que le monde des collectivités
locales qui sort de la crise du covid et
qui aborde aujourd'hui des questions
liées au coût de l'énergie et peut-être
capable en tout cas c'est ce qui est
ressorti des discussions qu'on a pu
avoir lors des auditions de la mission
RCT pour le projet de la finance 2023
capable d'autres dispositifs plus
responsabilisant que ceux qui sont
prévus dans le projet latinence donc
bien évidemment mais je pense que je
serai pas le seul à vous inviter à
regarder comment dans ce dispositif là
pourra évoluer dans la discussion du
budget au Sénat deuxième et le sujet qui
est un sujet important également et sans
doute un sujet différenciant entre la
position du Sénat et celle du
gouvernement c'est la question de la
suppression de la TVA
très honnêtement on est en train de tuer
l'un des derniers impôts locaux en
France
sans jamais qu'on est
vraiment réformé la fiscalité locale
dans son ensemble ni d'ailleurs réformer
la fiscalité de l'entreprise donc la CV
VAE qui est la prolongation de la
réforme de la TP dans notre pays qui et
nous a été vendu et survendu comme un
impôt dynamique rappelez-vous le
discours à l'époque ben c'est le dernier
le dernier impôt qui
est le lien entre la richesse produite
dans un territoire et des collectivités
locales qui aménagent et qui rendent des
services publics pour l'entreprise et
pour les salariés et pardon de le dire
moi qui vient d'un territoire industriel
en Haute-Savoie en particulier de la
vallée de l'arbre que quand on aura
définitivement supprimé le lien qui
existe entre l'industrie
et parfois les contraintes qu'elles
représentent et le territoire et ben
pour réindustrialiser le pays comme
d'ailleurs ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure par Bruno Le Maire dans la
missycle bon courage et on pourra créer
tout un tas de dispositifs palliatifs en
disant oui mais on recréera d'autres
manières de d'intéresser les territoires
à la présence sur sur
le territoire d'elle-même
d'intéresser les collectivités
sur le territoire desquels il y aura ces
implantations là et ben je pense qu'on
aura beaucoup de mal à recréer cet
intérêt alors que là il est direct et
vous savez si en France on a cette
appétence à l'impôt c'est aussi parce
que parfois on sait où c'est un pot va
et comment il est employé donc
différence de fond je sais qu'il y aura
des propositions soit de suppression de
de l'article de l'article 5 soit de
différer dans le temps cette réforme
mais encore une fois on supprime et on
ne remplace et on ne réfléchit pas à la
manière de financer les collectivités
territoriales avec celles et ceux qui
créent la richesse sur le territoire en
particulier les entreprises mais on
n'avait pas eu
on avait pas réussi gain de cause sur la
question des ménages puisque la taxe
d'habitation a été purement et
simplement supprimer et remplacé par des
compensations dernier point et pas le
moindre vous abordez monsieur le
ministre la question du fond vert c'est
une question qui est importante c'est de
2 milliards d'euros on sembler rassurer
que ce soit le préfet de département à
Nantes préfet de région qui qui attribue
ces
dotations on commence à voir une forme
de verdissement sur la des cils donc
comment est-ce que vous comment est-ce
que vous
allez harmoniser ces deux dispositifs là
et comment est-ce que et ça c'est d'une
petite marotte au Sénat ça vous
surprendra pas comment est-ce que vous
comptez associer les élus locaux
à au processus de décision de
l'attribution par le préfet de ce type
de choix parce que on a pu voir que
c'est parfois intéressant quand c'est la
DETR qui est tribué que les élus soient
associés c'est pas du tout le cas pour
la décile on a essayé à nous chaque
année de créer quelque chose qui permet
d'associer les îlots on n'y arrive pas
est-ce que là on aura un dispositif en
tout cas peut-être que nous nous aurons
des propositions qui permettront
d'associer les élus des territoires au
déploiement de cette deux grandes
politiques publiques que vous avez dans
votre propre famille ministériel
monsieur le ministre si monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur d'Arnaud
ensuite ce sera Monsieur Philippe Bas
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je vais pas
reprendre les points qui a évoqué le
rapporteur Loïc Hervé que je fais
aisément bien
j'ai écouté
attentivement vos propos tout à l'heure
lors de la question d'actualité qui vous
a été posée par le sénateur
collectionnateur des Hautes-Alpes
Jean-Michel Arnaud pour traduire les
inquiétudes tout à fait légitimes de nos
collectivités face à une situation aussi
inédite que douloureuse singulièrement
s'agissant de la question des des
énergies
je veux à mon tour vous livrer
aujourd'hui avec un peut-être un peu
plus de solennité qu'on peut le faire
d'habitude une inquiétude qui je crois
est une forme de poison assez assez
mortel pour l'avenir de nos
collectivités nous avons je crois en
responsabilité essayer de faire rutile
et comme je dis on l'ensemble du
Parlement le Sénat bien évidemment
lorsque nous avons apporté un concours à
se filer de la création ou la mise en
place de ce filet de sécurité
nous avions insisté alors un voisine
Françoise Gatel notamment mais beaucoup
d'autres aussi Loïc Hervé est en dot sur
le caractère opérationnel que de vrais
prendre ce dispositif et pourquoi je
parle de poison mortel c'est que les
maires ont déjà à faire face à des
dépenses inédites
nous leur devons
des dispositifs qui soient opérationnels
une parole de l'État qui soit tenue et
je le dis avec un peu d'amusement je
suis étonné moi petit sénateur de
l'Ardèche de recevoir de la part du
ministral
l'état des propositions de versements
sur sur l'avance pour le département de
l'Ardèche la semaine dernière et que le
ministre que vous êtes n'ayez pas à ce
stade l'état de des programmations de ce
filet de sécurité ce qui me rassure pas
au passage mais mais je reviens
à l'essentiel je crois qu'aujourd'hui si
ce qui a été engagé on peut tout à fait
aisément comprendre qu'après il faille
des critères et que les 22000 communes
qui rentraient potentiellement dans la
grille des éligibilité ne soit pas
nécessairement 22000 mais là aujourd'hui
le chiffre inquiète pour avoir
côtoyer et partager avec de nombreux
collègues les échanges qu'ils ont pu
avoir avec leur des défis dans les
départements je prends le cas de mon
département aujourd'hui 335 communes
beaucoup de communes rurales qui se
trouvent dans des situations très
compliquées en Ardèche on a 29 communes
qui rentrent dans le dispositif au titre
de l'avance qui a été évoqué c'est dire
si malheureusement ce filet de sécurité
n'est pas au rendez-vous et je livre des
éléments je peux vous donner même les
sommes qui ont été et qui ont été loués
donc je suis vraiment sur une approche
totalement pragmatique je n'exagère en
rien je suis vraiment sur quelque chose
de pragmatique mais quelle ne fut pas ma
surprise
quand plusieurs de mes collègues et
notamment le direct la directrice
départementale des finances me dit
attention parce qu'il se peut que ces
communes qui vont bénéficier de l'avance
soit obligé de les restituer pour partie
parce qu'on aura mal jugé des critères
au mois de mars ça je le dis ça n'est
pas possible et je le dis avec comme je
l'ai dit un peu de solennité et
peut-être un peu plus d'emportement que
d'habitude mais je crois que l'heure est
relativement grave pour que ensemble et
je dis bien ensemble parce qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'être les uns contre les
autres sur ce sujet parce qu'il en va
d'une crédibilité collective nos mères
qui ont à nourrir ou à faire preuve de
ce caractère anxiogène qui les dévore au
quotidien par rapport à ces difficultés
la moindre des choses c'est qu'on leur
donne un peu de transparence et de
clarté et puis je ne résiste pas alors
je sais que c'est pourtant d'habitude le
sujet préféré de Loïc Hervé parce que il
ne faut pas éclipser non plus d'autres
d'autres sujets importants sur des
dispositifs moi j'avais cru comprendre
en 2017 que le Président de la
République souhaitait que nous
réfléchissions à des dispositifs de
péréquation aujourd'hui je vois qu'on a
pas vraiment avancé sur la question mais
qu'en plus on a toujours pas réfléchi à
l'avenir d'un dispositif comme le SPIC
qui n'est pas sans poser de questions
pour les l'ensemble des collectivités
notamment par rapport aux effets de la
loi notre et puis un dernier point parce
que la ministre cailleux a fini sa
question d'actualité en faisant
référence
au rapport de la Cour des comptes qui
fait une proposition qui consisterait à
octroyer la DGF aux intercommunalités
avant que celle-ci ne redise pas de sous
ne redistribue cette DGF aux communes
voilà
je n'en dis pas plus je me tourne
simplement vers vous monsieur le
ministre pour connaître votre position
et votre sentiment sur sur la question
quand bien même il s'agit de
recommandations pour vous dire que la
solennité dont j'ai fait preuve dans mes
propos masque surtout une inquiétude par
rapport à l'avenir de nos territoires et
de nos communes je vous remercie merci
Monsieur d'Arnaud monsieur le questerba
ensuite monsieur benaroche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez un avantage
incontestable vous avez été présidente
conseil général vous avez été maire
d'une grande ville et vous avez même été
sénateurs
et par conséquent vous êtes
particulièrement bien placé pour avoir
la capacité de mettre des choses en
perspective
s'agissant de l'évolution de la capacité
financière de nos communes
sur moyenne période
parce que
à force d'avoir le nez collé sur le
pare-brise voiture on voit pas les
choses dans toute leur extension
j'aimerais que vous puissiez
pour éclairer le contexte du budget de
nous dire qu'elle aura été avec des
chiffres précis mais vous les avez
nécessairement l'évolution du pouvoir
d'achat de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement depuis 10 ans nous avons
eu des baisses de dotation à l'époque du
président François Hollande puis un gel
de dotation pendant de nombreuses années
et donc au fond quand d'une année sur
l'autre on fait un geste ce que je crois
vous vous apprêtez à faire il faut en
mesurer toute la portée en l'inscrivant
dans l'histoire des 10 dernières années
comme la baisse de capacité financière
de la dotation globale de fonctionnement
est en réalité très forte et que pendant
le même temps
notamment en raison des normes des
transferts de charges
de l'augmentation
cette année
légitime du traitement des
fonctionnaires
on a un effet de six eaux très important
et vous devez comprendre que quand on
ajoute à ce phénomène déjà complexe
la suppression d'un polo on se trouve
dans une situation qui justifie toute
l'inquiétude relayée par nos collègues
et notamment par Matthieu d'Arnaud sur
la situation financière des communes et
ceci sont mes estimés le fait que vous
avez annoncé des efforts certes limités
mais qui ont au moins le mérite
d'exister
ça c'est ma question principale vraiment
éclairez-nous sur le contexte de ce
budget 2023 après 10 ans d'érosion de la
capacité financière des dotations
globales de fonctionnement d'érosion
suivant une baisse
et puis je vous permettrait de vous
poser une question plus ponctuelle je
vous prends pas en trade parce que je
vous en ai parlé tout à l'heure
j'ai pu constater ça vous paraîtra
peut-être anecdotique mais je crois
qu'il faut être juste
dans toutes les situations il y a
quelques centaines de communes dans ce
cadre des petites communes certains
pourraient dire elles devraient même pas
exister mais elles existent
on calcule la dotation
pour le financement des indemnités des
élus locaux en fonction d'un coefficient
qui reflète
la richesse des habitants
et il arrive que quelqu'un emménage dans
la commune et qu'il est de gros moyens
alors d'un seul coup le maire qui
pourtant fait le même travail que
l'année dernière
se voit privé de toute capacité de
financement de son indemnité et de celle
de son seul adjoint je veux pas faire de
misérabilisme je pense que ça doit pas
l'état que de reconnaître le travail
d'autant plus grand que la commune est
petite d'un certain nombre de maires qui
consacre beaucoup de temps à leur
commune et qui se voit ainsi privés des
moyens de financer leur indemnité sans
augmenter les impôts je vais présenter
un amendement sur ce point et j'aimerais
déjà que vous lui apportiez un soutien
public ce qui lirait le gouvernement
pour le débat à venir
bien monsieur benaroche puis ensuite
Monsieur Alain Richard puis madame Gatel
puis madame cucarmann puis Monsieur
Dominique Théophile et Monsieur André
Richard et ensuite le ministre
oui oui oui oui
monsieur benaroche la condition des
questions soit court
je tiens à m'associer pleinement pour
que les choses soient bien comprises de
la position du Sénat globalement quelle
que soit les groupes aux inquiétudes et
oppositions qui ont été exprimées par
mes collègues Louis Mathieu Darnaud
en dehors de cela j'avais deux questions
particulières qui sont un peu plus
spécifiques à vous poser la première
part du du Costa du besoin réel
d'investissement dans les mobilités du
quotidien et du fait que le
développement des transports en commun
n'est pas le même sur l'ensemble du
territoire dans ce cadre et puis vous
savez très bien l'inquiétude aujourd'hui
des territoires ruraux avec les annonces
d'augmentation des péages SNCF réseau
dans les prochaines années et il y a
certains groupes de métropoles comme
celle d'où je viens très urbanisé ou le
développement des transports en commun
est loin d'être au même niveau
aujourd'hui que celui qui l'est par
exemple en Île-de-France
pour tout cela il y a certains
d'amendements qui ont été présentés sur
le versement militaire entreprise en
particulier alors pas dans le cadre du
PLF puisque ça n'avait pas pu être
étudié dans le cadre du PLF mais ils ont
été réintroduits dans le cadre du PLFR
ils ont été
rejetés hier avec un avis défavorable du
gouvernement bon
aucun aucune voie de la majorité
présidentielle sur ses amendements donc
ma question est avez-vous monsieur le
ministre des propositions à nous faire
dans le cadre de ce PLF pour permettre à
ces collectivités par exemple celle de
la métropole d'expertise Provos de
développer correctement
les mobilités nécessaires au
développement de leur à leur
développement voilà
je dirais juste une chose c'est
versement mobilité entreprise c'est ses
amendements avec pour vocation de rendre
un taux maximum compatible et égal à
celui qui est aujourd'hui dans la région
parisienne je rajouterais une dernière
chose là-dessus les élus de la région du
Bouches-du-Rhône que ce soit les élus de
républicains qui ont voté aussi contre
ces amendements que ce soit les élus
lrem vos députés localement en défendu
l'augmentation ou en tout cas ces
amendements
identiques
pour ces métropoles à ce à ceux de Paris
deuxième question c'est aller beaucoup
plus courte
vous connaissez vraisemblablement parce
que vous avez ce dossier aussi entre les
mains les problèmes des péréquations
liés entre autres aux attributions de
compensation ou dotation de solidarité
des communes de la métropole
d'Aix-Marseille Provence vous savez très
bien que c'est commune essaie
aujourd'hui à la métropole tente de
mettre en oeuvre les dispositions
prévues par la loi 3DS qui ont été voté
ici vous savez également que la
publication du rapport de la cour des
côtes le 20 octobre a montré à certains
nombre de choses d'or en particulier que
178 millions d'assés avaient été versés
et du Mans il y a donc un besoin de
visibilité pour la métropole avoir des
décisions qui doivent être prises au 31
décembre je voulais savoir si vous étiez
disposé à intégrer dans ce PLF un
mécanisme progressif par voie
d'amendement pour progressif et lycée
qui pourraient corriger l'État qui a été
dénoncé et pour lequel il est demandé à
la métropole d'être dur à certains de
modification va
en 2023 si Monsieur Richard
complété de quelques mots l'observation
de du rapporteur Hervé sur le fond vert
parce que j'ai vu dans les publications
spécialisées ces derniers jours des
esquisses de répartition par paquet de
dizaines de millions de ce fond vert
dont je perçois mal la pertinence à
partir d'un schéma qui normalement
devrait être celui d'une répartition par
les préfets de départements sur dossiers
tout simple donc si vous pouviez nous
préciser que vous allez émettre dans un
délai assez proche une circulaire guide
sur l'utilisation du fond vert à
destination des préfets et des élus qui
sont les utilisateurs
et si vous pouviez vous assurer qu'il y
aura un délai suffisant parce qu'on a eu
quelques expériences douloureuses pour
les communes pour présenter leur dossier
qui sont pas tous très simples des
dossiers de l'efficacité énergétique
ce serait tout à fait bienvenu
sur la le fonctionnement du filet de
sécurité de 2022
il m'a semblé me rendre compte notamment
en observant le débat de l'Assemblée
nationale que nos amis le ministre de
l'économie et le ministre du compte
public avait un peu de marge en sortie
d'exécution de 1022
ça les avait donc rendus un peu réceptif
il me semble qu'on pourrait progresser
encore un peu sur le filet de sécurité
pour surmonter l'effet de falaise du de
la clause des 25%. vous allez avoir une
quantité de communes ou d'intercaux qui
a quelques milliers d'euros près vont
manquer la cible des 25% et d'ailleurs
j'en connais un certain nombre qui sont
en train de faire un travail discret
d'optimisation de leur futur contenu
administratif pour tomber du bon côté si
j'ose dire il me semble donc qu'il
serait pas déraisonnable de créer un
deuxième étage pour les collectivités
qui font entre -20 et -25 de baisse
d'excédent avait peut-être des
pourcentages de remboursement moins
élevés mais qu'il n'y ait pas tout ou
rien
troisièmement
n'étant pas polytechnicien je n'ai à peu
près rien compris à la présentation de
la première ministre qui elle est quant
au système de l'amortissement
électricité
donc pour les
ignorants et ceux dont les souvenirs de
physique se perdent dans les décennies
il me semble que ce serait bien que le
gouvernement édite un document
d'explication du fonctionnement du de
l'amortisseur électricité parce qu'il
sera sans doute judicieux mais pour
l'instant personne ne voit vraiment
l'usage qu'on peut en faire
et dernier point
il est
favorable que les collectivités de
petites dimensions c'est à dire moins de
2 millions et moins de 10 emplois
guillemets
soit dans le TRV sauf que les
collaborateurs de votre collègue Gabriel
Attal m'ont précisé que c'était des
emplois et pas des ETP
or dans cette catégorie de collectivités
vous avez évidemment beaucoup de
collectivités qui additionnent un
certain nombre de petits emplois à temps
partiel pour le scolaire pour les
services techniques etc et qui vont
franchir le cap des 10 emplois et ne
seront plus bénéficiaires du comment du
tarif réglementé alors qu'ils sont à
moins de 10 ETP donc si on pouvait faire
ce petit effort ça aiderait à régler ce
problème là merci si Monsieur Achard
imaginez quand on est ni politique ni
politique ni et Dark on comprend plus
rien c'est fini
nous le vivons tous les jours en tous
les cas voici me concerne dans ce
ministre madame Gatel
c'est monsieur le Président merci au
rapporteur monsieur le ministre avant de
parler d'argent
j'aimerais qu'on enfin qu'on évoque ce
qui lit l'État et les collectivités nous
assurer que nous sommes d'accord parce
que tout part de là je rappelle que
l'action publique elle est conduite par
l'État et des collectivités que les
collectivités quand on emploie ce mot il
y a tel gens qui savent pas ce que c'est
mais les collectivités rendent des
services essentiels à la population pour
le compte de l'État donc n'oublions
jamais cela et que les choses vont mieux
quand on souhaite et je sais que vous
vous le souhaitez le président de la
République l'a dit une relation de
partenariat responsable et confiant
entre l'État et les collectivités donc
il faut d'abord qu'on réaffirme ça et
puis si on affirment ça veut dire il y a
des choses qu'on va rapidement balayer
le grand cru de Cahors monsieur le
ministre a pas eu le succès qu'on mérité
je veux dire aujourd'hui
soit on entend et on est d'accord que
les collectivités sont conduites par des
élus responsables mais qui ont des
missions à rendre dont les considérants
des missions sont parfois fixées par
l'État par l'administration et qu'un
certain nombre de normes et je pense
qu'on parlera pas beaucoup de sujets
mais moi j'aimerais qu'on le rappelle
donc ceci veut dire qu'à un moment s'il
y a un pacte financier
parlons-en mais Monsieur le Ministre ici
on a une religion qui est assez simple
qui est très républicaine qui est de
dire qu'il décide paie
et qui assume doit pouvoir décider alors
je vais lire un petit mot quand même sur
la CVAE j'entends que le gouvernement a
bon escient réfléchit
à cette affaire annoncée comme une
disparition constatera un petit peu
voilà la CVAE monsieur le ministre a été
dit c'est le lien entre les
collectivités qui décident de faire du
développement économique et l'entreprise
qui s'installe et que il y a une menace
autour de nous et vous le savez bien que
s'appelle le zan cette curiosité qui
fait que on va devoir un moment choisir
entre l'habitat et le développement
économique quand en plus le
développement économique soulève de la
part de nos concitoyens du
mécontentement vous avouez s'il n'y a
pas les recettes ça n'est pas très
incitatif donc moi je vous invite à
chasser
de votre esprit l'idée de la disparition
de la C VAE mais si vous y tenez
si vous y tenez autre chose sur lequel
il faut réfléchir c'est la C3S moi j'ai
proposé un amendement hier au PLFSS
alors on peut me dire que c'était pas le
sujet sauf que cette taxe qui est payé
par des entreprises qui font 19 millions
d'euros qui rapportent 3 millions six à
l'état et qui est destiné au financement
de la vieillesse coûterait beaucoup
moins cher en compensation à l'état que
la CVAE donc monsieur le ministre vous
noterez qu'une fois de plus le Sénat est
très aidant et très proposant de grâce
réfléchissez aux belles économies qu'on
peut vous faire faire une question sur
le le filet de sécurité et je monsieur
le Président notre collègue animal de
Souali m'a demandé d'élargir au champ
ultramarins cette question les collègues
ont dit monsieur le ministre que le
filet de sécurité
c'est quand même un peu un peu compliqué
moi je salue le geste qui a été fait va
en même temps comme il a été inventé par
Bercy je vous avoue et j'aurais pas de
désagréable mais pour moi c'est un peu
comme quand je passe devant une banque
et que je vois entrer ici vous pourrez
faire tous les prêts que vous voulez et
j'arrive et le banquier me dit Madame en
ont été ravi mais votre taux
d'endettement qui devrait être limité à
30 il est à 31 donc on pourra pas faire
et sincèrement monsieur le ministre moi
je salue l'effort qui a été fait mais ce
filet de sécurité il est très compliqué
il est archi verrouillé il ne sera pas
utilisé aujourd'hui parce que on ne
connaîtra
l'état de la troisième cause qu'en avril
ou mars
[Musique]
2023 et que vous le savez bien beaucoup
de nos communes aujourd'hui ont été
écartées de ce sujet donc je salue
l'effort qu'il vaut de vouloir
reconduire ce système en 2023 mais
est-ce qu'on peut le simplifier
est-ce qu'on peut juste mettre
de la conscience de la réalité des
choses et pas simplement de l'équation
polytechnicienne je vais vous donner un
exemple une commune de mon département
était normalement éligible sauf que la
malheureuse qui n'a pas les moyens de
faire d'optimisation fiscale parce que
c'est pas que son niveau il se trouve
que dans une des années de référence à
la fin virement de son budget
d'assainissement
au budget principal recette
exceptionnelle dont le défi a raté vous
n'auriez pas dû donc est-ce que vous
allez en 2023
améliorer les choses parce que et j'en
terminerai là enfin non j'ai un petit
point encore monsieur le ministre la
gravité du sujet c'est pas que les
collectivités
vont se faire une santé financière c'est
que si les collectivités elles craignent
2023 et 2024 elles vont faire un budget
d'investissement à zéro quasi ce qui
veut dire que le moteur de l'économie
dans nos entreprises ont besoin va être
un peu bloqués et que donc monsieur le
ministre on sera encore obligé
d'inventer des caisses de secours et
puis dernier point plus joyeux
en 2020 sans dit comme je vous assure
j'y mets tout mon coeur en 2020 sans dix
communes n'ont pas eu de candidat aux
élections en 2014 elles étaient 80 c'est
quand même un sujet et on voit
aujourd'hui les démissions alors moi je
pense que voilà il y a sans doute des
solutions mais il existe une chose qui
est une pépite législative d'exception
puisque sont les seuls élus qui peuvent
le faire c'est la commune nouvelle or
aujourd'hui ce dispositif et vous le
connaissez bien dans votre département
ce dispositif qui permet à des élucides
le souhaitent de garder la proximité de
la commune et l'efficacité et victimes
et victimes de conditions financières
qui font que quand vous faites une
commune nouvelle pour muscler votre
proximité donner de l'efficacité il
arrive un moment où vous perdez de
l'argent mais sincèrement donc
entendez-vous avoir de meilleures
intentions à l'égard de ces dis merci
monsieur le ministre et n'oubliez pas
l'ultra marin
si vous nous arrivez à écouter le
ministre il faut réduire le temps des
questions
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'aurais envie de dire
et l'heure est grave non pas pour les
élus leur est grave tout simplement pour
notre pays elle est grave parce que je
pense que
dans un pays comme le nôtre au vu y
compris même des enjeux climatiques des
années à venir quand dans une
collectivité on fait le pari du
réchauffement climatique pour pouvoir
passer l'hiver et ainsi pouvoir
économiser fortement les dépenses de
fluides et maintenir un internat un
lycée un collège une école une salle des
fêtes ou tout autre équipement public je
crois qu'on arrive dans une situation
totalement
ubuesque ou pour le coup là les élus ne
savent plus par quel bout prendre les
choses et y compris comment faire pour
arriver à continuer de satisfaire les
besoins des populations au sein de leur
collectivité territoriale l'heure est
grave parce que et je ne remets pas en
cause
nous avons su quand le confinement a été
décrété débloquer les moyens nécessaires
indispensables pour maintenir le niveau
social de notre pays pour accompagner
les entreprises qui du jour au lendemain
s'arrêter
et pour autant
la situation qui est en train de se
passer au collectivités très
certainement être la cause dans les mois
qui viennent d'un plan de licenciement
certainement très silencieux mais
massifs dans l'ensemble de nos
territoires parce que si les communes
n'ont plus demain la capacité à investir
ce sont nos entreprises nos TPE nos
artisans de toutes ces activités non
délocalisables qui vont être les
premières les victimes et elles le sont
déjà elles le sont déjà parce que
l'investissement a commencé à réduire et
voilà ce n'est pas la faute de tel ou
tel on est dans une dans une situation
économique que nous connaissons elles le
sont parce que déjà la hausse du coût
des matériaux à jouer sur l'année la fin
de l'année 2021 et l'année 2022 invitant
un certain nombre de nos collectivités y
compris celles ayant eu bénéficié d'un
certain nombre de dotations à renoncer à
leurs projets d'investissement ou alors
à le réduire j'écoute tu m'as dire à
faire trois fenêtres 2004 et donc tout
ceci a des incidences et donc je crois
que c'est à la hauteur de ces enjeux là
qu'il faut prendre bien évidemment la
réponse et donc vous comprenez bien que
quand nous découvrons ces derniers jours
le nombre de communes bénéficiaires du
filet de sécurité dans les départements
ça interpelle 323 communes dans le
département de la Loire 13 sont
éligibles et encore même envie de vous
poser la question pourquoi certaines et
pas d'autres parce que si demain nous
rendions très publiquement cette liste
on peut mettre le feu sur les
territoires et je vous dis mais c'est
pas et ce n'est pas le souhait mais
parce que vous voyez ce qui est simple
c'est non simplement moi je
vous le dis voilà très très simplement
réécoutez la réponse que vous avez
faites lors des questions d'actualité
alors je suis désolé je fais une
hypotechnique ni Lena à part ça sinon
voilà je pense avoir quand même pas trop
rater ma vie mais bon peut-être que
voilà mais je vous assure que même avec
des connaissances un peu voilà maîtriser
y compris des finances locales qui sont
les nôtres la situation est très
compliquée et va donc générer beaucoup
de difficultés donc je crois que pour
2023 d'abord il faut débloquer les fonds
suffisant pour répondre aux besoins que
j'ai donc pas satisfaire les mères et
expliquer trouver les choses plus
simples je rappellerai aussi que en
période d'inflation les recettes de TVA
de l'État ne baisse pas et que donc la
question de réindexation totale partiel
chacun le dira comme il le souhaite
quand même de la DGF sur l'inflation se
pose et elle se pose d'autant plus que
j'ai bien entendu ce que vous avez dit
avec le fond vert
mais le fond vert c'est de l'aide à
l'investissement et voyez la boucle est
bouclée je vais vous redire la même
chose que j'ai dit à Madame Gouro au
moment de la dotr et de la décile de
relance c'est très bien pour ceux qui
peuvent mais ceux qui ne peuvent pas
mettre les 20% et bien finalement on
continue de fracturer un peu plus encore
dans nos territoires la différence entre
les collectivités donc faisons attention
à cela bien évidemment qu'il y ait des
dispositifs pour aider accompagner
sécuriser davantage d'investissement oui
mais la difficulté de nos collectivités
aujourd'hui c'est aussi sur le
fonctionnement comment je vais faire et
ça quand le fonctionnement sera payé
c'est la capacité à investir qui est
réduite et donc ça ceci qu'il faut je
crois que dans le projet de loi de
finances nous puissions y répondre force
et de constater aujourd'hui que on en
est encore loin merci beaucoup monsieur
théophile
monsieur le ministre en outre-mer il y a
des communes qui ont signé un dispositif
qui s'appelle le Corum le contrat de
redressement outre-mer est-ce que vous
pouvez nous confirmer que ces communes
vont
disposer bénéficieront en 2023 du filet
de sécurité inflation
c'est une question courte précise merci
très bien parfait félicitations
ce sera court aussi monsieur le
Président désolé monsieur le ministre de
vous remettre une couche sur le filet de
sécurité
mais je me dois moi aussi
je me dois moi aussi de vous dire la
situation de mon département plus de 500
communes 28 communes éligibles et très
franchement pour faire court j'ose même
pas pleurer avec les communes concernées
parce que toucher 1000 euros 1000 euros
sans être sûr de pouvoir les garder le
ikervé vous disait c'est quand même un
vrai problème moi j'ai été de ceux qui
dès le PLF voté à largement relayée
l'effort qui a été fait à cet égard
notamment à la suite des travaux menés
par le Sénat mal m'en a pris parce que
je le ferai plus jamais parce que vous
avez compris que les communes qui ont
touché cet acompte ne m'ont pas oublié
donc moi pour faire très court je milite
vraiment pour un discours clair
à l'avenir en la matière c'est quoi le
filet de sécurité je rejoins tout à fait
ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure on en
plus je suis pas une arc je suis pas
polytechnicien j'ai pas d'informations
claires en ce qui concerne notamment euh
l'amortissement l'amortisseur dont a
parlé madame la Première ministre mais
voilà un discours clair
si possible avec une véritable prise en
compte des besoins des collectivités qui
souffrent le plus à cet égard et et avec
des sommes qui correspondent un peu à
quelque chose merci merci pour terminer
Monsieur Didier Marie ensuite c'est le
Ministre à la parole merci monsieur le
Président et tant sur votre aile gauche
j'avais un peu échappé à votre sagacité
lorsque j'avais levé le doigt mais je
suis le dernier donc je vais essayer de
ne pas être trop long c'est certainement
le meilleur pour la fin je vous remercie
madame Gatel
ce ministre vous vous nous présentez une
version
positive
du volet collectivité de ce budget et
vous souligner un certain nombre
d'améliorations et si on était en dehors
du contexte le cas échéant si nous
avions été l'année dernière on aurait pu
se féliciter d'un certain nombre de
décisions qui sont prises
le problème c'est que il y a le contexte
et le contexte c'est que les
collectivités d'une part sortent de la
crise du covid et bon nombre d'entre
elles ont été malmenées et encore
quelques difficultés à assumer que notre
part suite au conflit
avec en Ukraine
nous connaissons aujourd'hui à la fois
une flambée du coup l'énergie et
implique de l'inflation les deux se
répercutant massivement sur le budget de
nos collectivités
ça a été dit par un certain nombre de
mes collègues précédemment et je ne vais
pas aller plus loin dessus que les
indicateurs de précarité dans nos
collectivités
augmentent il faut savoir que 85% selon
un récent sondage des Françaises et des
Français disent qu'il va falloir se
serrer la ceinture qu'elles sont
commencés à le faire et ceci pour les
plus pauvres d'entre eux se traduit par
des afflux dans nos CCAS ou
fabrication de solidarité des
départements à cela s'ajoute un certain
nombre de décisions positives certes
prise par l'État mais qui s'impose aux
collectivités sans être compensées le
point d'indice pour la fonction publique
territoriale l'augmentation
des rémunérations des aesh
l'augmentation du RSA l'avenant 43 pour
l'aide sociale des départements sans
parler de la gemapi qui a aussi des
répercussions sur les finances locales
et donc dans ce contexte vous prenez des
décisions qui sont particulièrement
malvenues la première c'est la
suppression de la CVAE ça a été dit le
dernier lien entre le territoire et le
monde économique et le dernier impôt
puissant qui
nous revenait et qui va disparaître
vous allez remplacer par la TVA vous
nous dites aujourd'hui que c'est très
positif le TVA par définition est un
impôt volatile qui en fonction de la
situation économique peut varier et peut
donc varier y compris à la baisse
d'ailleurs la suppression de la tvae a
aussi des conséquences sur les fonds de
péréquation notamment des départements
il sera intéressant à ce sujet que vous
puissiez nous dire comment les choses
vont se passer
au final tout cela nous amène à un
risque de panne de l'investissement
local ça a été aussi mentionné par nos
collègues et moi j'aurais une question à
vous poser monsieur le ministre
la creux a annoncé hier ou avant-hier
que l'État les percevoir 30,9 milliards
d'euros au titre de ce que les
producteurs d'énergie renouvelables
devaient lui verser soit 20 milliards
d'euros de plus
que ce qui a été perçu l'année
précédente est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas pouvoir récupérer une
partie de ces 20 milliards d'euros pour
d'une part indexé la DGF sur l'inflation
ce qui est une demande forte de
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales améliorer le filet de
sécurité et répondre à un certain nombre
de revendications des associations
d'élus merci Monsieur marie bien écoute
nous avons terminé avec les questions
sur le ministre vous avez la parole
écoutez un grand merci c'est varié
c'est précis
et ça va me permettre sur un certain
nombre de sujets
de vous parler de manière extrêmement
cash à la fois en partageant des points
on en découvrant d'autres et à l'inverse
de vous dire ma part de vérité sur
certains sur lesquels je suis en
désaccord avec les analyses que vous
faites
contrat CVAE filet fond vert c'est les
quatre sujets principaux autour desquels
d'une partie des discussions ont tourné
je veux tout de suite répondre à la
question la plus courte par la réponse
la plus courte et dire au sénateur
Théophile que oui les communes qui sont
dans le Corum peuvent bénéficier du
filet il y a pas de sujets d'exclusion
ou d'absence de possibilités
d'appartenir aux deux dispositifs de
manière simultanée
alors on commence par le contrat
je suis nommé le 20 mai les discussions
sur qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pendant ce
mandat commence et pour être extrêmement
clair avec vous l'entrée dans la
discussion entre les collectivités
territoriales et Bercy c'est Bercy qui
dit qu'il faut qu'on imagine des
contrats de Cahors bis nouvelle version
éventuellement pour varier un peu les
plaisirs en se basant peut-être sur la
capacité d'autofinancement plutôt que
sur l'évolution des dépenses de
fonctionnement et une position qui est
celle qui s'est imposée qui consiste à
dire un on est dans une période
d'inflation qui fait que se baser sur
les dépenses de fonctionnement n'a pas
de sens de
indépendamment du caractère
effectif ou pas des contrats de Cahors
le signal qui consiste à dire nous ne
faisons pas confiance aux collectivités
locales et on pense que vous allez mal
gérer donc vous allez signer un document
dans lequel vous allez vous engager à
bien gérer a été catastrophique il a été
en termes de climat pour les
collectivités locales ce que la façon
dont les 35 heures ont été votées ont
été pour les entreprises c'est à dire
cette idée que moi on travaille mieux
c'est et cette idée que plus pour dans
le monde du travail indépendamment des
effets ensuite entreprises par
entreprise et si je transpose cette idée
que en gros il y a d'un côté l'État qui
est vertueux de l'autre les
collectivités locales qui par nature
sont dépensières
stopper ce mécanisme en évitant qu'on
est un contrat qui soit un contrat
individuel en évitant qu'on ait des
dispositifs qui soient automatiques ça a
été ce à quoi je me suis employé en
recevant toutes les associations des
lieux au début du mois de juillet avec
Gabriel Attal en ne cachant pas qu'il y
avait plusieurs hypothèses sur la table
et en arrivant sur un point d'équilibre
qui était dire ok pas de contraintes
un mécanisme dans lequel nous appliquons
quelque chose qui existe depuis
longtemps qui s'appelle l'eau de Dell
qui est l'objectif d'évolution des
dépenses des collectivités locales moins
connues que l'on dame mais qui fait
partie des textes budgétaires sur
lesquels nous nous prononçons au fur et
à mesure du temps qui permet de traduire
ce qu'est la perspective ou la
trajectoire sur laquelle nous sommes et
on verra sur la base des contes
administratifs 2023 c'est-à-dire mi-2024
si on a des collectivités qui se sont
écartées de cette trajectoire et si
c'est le cas là il y aura des
rendez-vous qui se feront de manière
spécifique avec les préfets pour garder
s'il y a des éléments conjoncturels qui
permettent d'expliquer les dépassements
ou si au contraire il y a une nécessité
de faire en sorte d'établir des
trajectoires de retour à l'équilibre et
c'est sur ces bases que le PLF pardon
que la loi de programmation des finances
publiques s'est engagée
l'attitude de la majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale nous a conduit à ce que la LPF
soit dévitalisée qu'elle ne puisse pas
être adoptée c'est pas une posture on
est en commission je suis pas dans
l'hémicycle le sujet c'est pas de me
faire applaudir ou uuer et je veux vous
dire que la réalité de ce qu'est le
respect d'une trajectoire
maastrichtienne d'une évolution de nos
dépenses publiques c'est une obligation
européenne et ça une conséquence c'est
l'appréciation par les prêteurs de la
solidité de notre trajectoire et donc de
nos niveaux de ton intérêt on peut faire
comme si ça n'existait pas on peut
considérer que c'est pas un sujet
moins ça on sera
au niveau de la représentation nationale
et du gouvernement plus un deviendra un
pour nos finances publiques nationales
et locales parce que ça aura un impact
sur nos taux d'intérêt
rassurer les marchés sur le fait qu'on
est sur une trajectoire soutenable de
retour à une trajectoire d'équilibre
qui n'est pas la plus
rapide de l'Union européenne en envoyant
des signaux sur le fait que il faut
qu'on diminue le poids de nos dépenses
publiques est une nécessité
ma conviction c'est qu'il faut revenir à
l'esprit initial de ces contrats de
confiance
l'absence d'accord sur l'afpfp nous a
conduit à réintroduire par voie
d'amendement le dispositif on imaginant
un mécanisme qui soit d'autant plus dur
qu'il est provisoire l'exposé des motifs
de l'article 23 dans le cadre du PDF
précise qu'il s'agisse seulement d'un
mécanisme provisoire et vous verrez la
beauté du provisoire c'est qu'il ne
pourrait pas s'appliquer de toute façon
avant 2024 puisqu'il faudrait quand même
que ce soit sur la comparaison des
comptes administratives 23 par rapport
au compte administratif 22 qu'on puisse
considérer qu'il y a eu un écart par
rapport à la trajectoire telle qu'elle
avait été définie donc s'échapper sur un
dispositif théorique je pense qu'il y a
des chemins de compromis le chemin de
compromis auquel nous appelons le Sénat
c'est quand même un moment que sur une
trajectoire de finance publique on
s'entende sur le fait que c'est on est
tous dans le même bateau et qu'à un
moment indépendamment des différences de
gestion y compris juridique qui peuvent
exister entre l'État et collectivités
locales à la fin il y a un contribuable
qui ne se demande pas si l'impôt il est
national ou s'il est local qui constate
si ça a des conséquences ou sur son
pouvoir d'achat et je pense là dessus
vraiment qu'on a des marges parce que je
ne souhaite pas un dispositif qui
recréer un climat de défiance il y a
suffisamment de sujets sur lesquels il
faut être capable de recréer la
confiance pour que on évite sur celui-là
de s'écarter de ce qui était la
philosophie initiale et je vous assure
qu'on est ouvert dans le cadre de la LFP
de la LPFP et de la CMP dans le cadre du
PLF à trouver une manière en particulier
sur le titre 4 de cet article 23 qui
concerne les dispositifs de sanctions
à être collectivement intelligent
sur le filet de sécurité
pardon je vais répondre dans l'ordre des
questions du rapporteur pour avis et
donc sur la CV
je voulais alterner les points sur
lesquels j'avais des désaccords et les
points sur lesquels j'avais des accords
et j'ai beaucoup d'accord avec ce que
vous avez dit sur le filet de sécurité
c'est pour ça que je voulais alterner
sur la CV je suis en désaccord et je
vais vous dire pourquoi
pour 3 raisons la première elle est
fondamentale et les politiques et ne
relève pas des finances publiques mais
peut-être d'une conception un peu vieux
jeu de la politique c'est que je
considère que quand on prend un
engagement devant les électeurs on le
tient
le président de la République a été élu
en prenant un engagement extrêmement
clair sur les électeurs ne pas tenir cet
engagement de mon point de vue c'est
alimenter cette idée que les hommes
politiques se présentent aux élections
en faisant des promesses et que une fois
élu ils peuvent s'en affranchir certains
diront c'est dommage qu'il respecte
celle-là pourquoi est-ce que j'observe
une chose c'est que il y a un engagement
et le sujet c'est le de le tenir ensuite
il y a de faux arguments pour justifier
la défense de la CV
il me semblait que la majorité
sénatoriale pendant longtemps en tout
cas au moment où j'avais l'honneur d'y
appartenir avec deux convictions trois
convictions très fortes la première
c'est la nécessité de considérer que la
gestion des deniers publics nécessite de
considérer que la dette n'est pas un
grand mot et qu'il faut y être attentif
parce que si on fait pas attention à la
dette à un moment ou un autre ce sont
nos créanciers qui font appel à qui qui
se préoccupe de nous
mais que dans le même temps le poids des
prélèvements obligatoires en France
sensiblement supérieur à la moyenne des
pays de l'Union européenne était un
problème voire même était un frein pour
notre attractivité économique
et qu'à la fin il y avait quand même un
principe qui était celui de la
responsabilité des élus qui fallait être
capable de préserver au milieu de tout
ça
j'entends l'argument qui consiste à dire
vous supprimez la CVAE et donc on se
prive de recettes publiques celui-là il
est discutable il consiste à savoir si
en baissant un impôt qui pèse sur les
entreprises on stimule l'activité en
générant un surplus de recettes fiscales
supérieur à la perte
en revanche sur l'autonomie des
collectivités locales nous avons perdu
le pouvoir de taux pardon les élus
locaux ont perdu le pouvoir de taux
quand on a créé la CVA vous n'avez pas
de taux il y a pas d'autonomie fiscale
lié à la CVAE vous avez un impôt
national avec une répartition et donc le
sujet quand on remplace une part de CVAE
par une part de TVA on ne substitue pas
un impôt sur lequel les élus auraient un
pouvoir de taux par un impôt sur lequel
ils n'ont pas de pouvoir de tout il y a
un bon argument
comment est-ce qu'on évite qu'en
supprimant un impôt qui reflète
l'attractivité économique du territoire
on ne désincite les élus mais c'est pas
sur l'autonomie fiscale c'est sur la
politique qui va être conduite au niveau
économique surtout dans un contexte où
le zan peut créer une tension j'assume
pleinement ce point et on aura des
occasions d'en discuter
d'abord
je tiens à dire et ce sera ma réponse à
Didier et Marie sur ce point que
très objectivement là aussi à la fin le
point qui a été arbitré par la première
ministre c'est une dynamique qui va
coûter plus cher au finances publiques
que ce qui était le dispositif
initialement prévu si nous avions
remplacé la CVE par un prélèvement sur
recette ça c'est du déjà vu le nombre de
fois que l'État n'a pas par le passé
respecté scrupuleusement la tendance des
prélèvements sur recettes on les
rabotant au fur et à mesure de
l'histoire on ne les compte plus et
d'autre part
la dynamique n'est jamais acquise
les choses sont totalement différentes à
partir du moment où le gouvernement a
décidé de remplacer la CVE par la TVA
oui c'est un impôt volatile la CVAE
aussi
et la TVA est nettement moins volatile
que la CVA
pour être clair la dernière fois que la
TVA a baissé dans ce pays c'était il y a
13 ans c'était en 2009 la dernière fois
que la CVAE a baissé dans ce pays
c'était il y a 3 ans mais les variations
de ces VAE à l'échelle d'un territoire
elles sont beaucoup plus importantes
parce qu'elles reflètent ce qui se passe
en moyenne depuis 10 ans la CVA c'est
2,5% de progression par an en moyenne
depuis 10 ans la TVA c'est 3,5 de
progression de crédit par an et si nous
revenons avec de l'inflation je tiens à
vous le dire la TVA à une vertu c'est
que comme elle est indexée sur les prix
elle permet de compenser une partie de
tout ça et d'ailleurs vous remarquerez
que dans le débat fiscal il y a une
strate de collectivité qu'on entend un
peu moins que les autres ce sont les
régions
parce que les progressions les recettes
de TVA des régions sont de 9%
pour une raison simple c'est que ça
reflète la progression dont je suis en
train de parler et dès lors que l'État
ne capte pas la compensation pour les
collectivités qui ont déjà vu une part
une fraction de TVA remplacer d'autres
fractions de fiscalité elle n'envisage
pas plus de le faire demain dans le
cadre du remplacement de la CVE et donc
on aura un dispositif qui sera
beaucoup plus en lien avec les
différents cycles économiques en termes
de qualité de compensation
en revanche il faut traiter la question
de comment un territoire qui fait plus
pour accueillir des entreprises est
accompagnée et c'est le mécanisme qui
repose sur une partie de progression des
bases calculée sur la CFE et sur une
partie de la progression des effectifs
de manière à ce qu'on garde ce lien en
terme de dynamique et j'entends la
proposition sur les C3S
sauf que là aussi je suis entré dans ce
débat très objectivement en demandant à
ce qu'on me présente les arguments
laisser 3S et le porte principalement
sur les services sur la banque sur les
assurances là où la CVAE objectivement
et deux fois plus intense pour les
entreprises industrielles puisque 25% du
montant de la CVE et payé par des
entreprises industrielles alors même
qu'elles ne représente que 10% des
emplois et donc
si on souhaite réindustrialiser et j'ai
entendu des voix fortes encore cet
après-midi au moment des QG le fait est
que la CVAE est un meilleur impôt à
supprimer pour soutenir l'industrie
le filet de sécurité
je suis
édifié par les chiffres que j'ai entendu
cet après-midi et je vous assure que je
vais remonter et faire me faire remonter
les analyses qui ont été faites par
département
fort de ce que vous me dites sur le
filet de sécurité 2022 ça renforce ma
conviction que le filet de sécurité 2023
doit être améliorée et je vais plus loin
qu'à la Richard
à 25% la porte
est trop étroite
et je pense qu'à 20% elle l'est encore
trop
et qu'il faut être capable d'aller plus
bas
parce que si vraiment le nombre de
collectivités qui bénéficient d'un filet
de sécurité dimensionné à 430 millions
d'euros ce chiffre à 10 ou 15 % des
collectivités
dès lors qu'on multiplie par plus de 3
le montant qu'on envisage de consacrer
ce serait aberrant qu'on annonce un
chiffre qui me semble être en phase avec
les besoins de couverture du delta de
l'amortisseur je vais essayer n'étant ni
polytechnicien niénarque malgré tout de
revenir quelques instants sur le
dispositif moi non plus finalement il y
en a aucun d'entre eux aussi il y a
Philippe bar il y a un la Richard il y
en a quand même quelques-uns tout va
bien
je reviens à mon sujet
le filet de sécurité
dans le cadre de la co-construction
il a été topé entre le gouvernement et
le Sénat qui comprit
à contribué à ouvrir la porte si malgré
le fait que vous l'ayez davantage ouvert
et moi j'avais en tête ce chiffre de
22000 communes on se retrouve avec un
nombre très éloigné je considère que
nous sommes engagés par le montant
financier que nous avons mis sur la
table et qu'il faut qu'on regarde
comment nous sommes au rendez-vous d'une
promesse de soutien aux collectivités
territoriales en termes de pouvoir
d'achat et il faut qu'on s'inspire de ça
suffisamment vite pour en tirer les
leçons pour le dispositif 2023 je
prétends 45% non seulement on est trop
restrictif mais qu'on est tous au crime
pour où creuser un déficit 2022 qui
permet de justifier qu'en 2023 on a une
baisse de sa capacité d'autofinancement
qui soit plus importante ou pour ne pas
faire les arbitrages au titre de l'année
2023 qui consisterait à limiter
certaines dépenses pour assurer des
pentes qui soient plus élevées donc je
partage totalement et je considère dans
la foulée du sénateur Richardt qu'on a
tous dit qu'on soit sénateur ou membres
du gouvernement qu'on était en train de
voter des dispositifs de soutien et que
si demain à cause de ces modalités les
sommes ne sont pas au rendez-vous
une part de crédibilité de notre parole
publique qui est abîmée là où il n'y a
pas de loup c'est que les sommes elles
sont inscrites pour leur montant nominal
on ne construit pas un dispositif pour
essayer de restreindre le nombre de
bénéficiaires on commence par dire
quelle est la somme qu'on y consacre et
ensuite on imagine le dispositif donc
dans le cadre de la Somme n'hésitez pas
à regarder comment on peut élargir le
dispositif il y a trois principaux
sujets la porte d'entrée et il faut
retoucher à ses 25% pour les diminuer et
ensuite il y a le mécanisme qui consiste
à prendre à condition que les recettes
d'énergie et progresser 60% plus vite
que les recettes réelles de
fonctionnement 50% de ce delta de 60%
réel peut-être que y compris dans la
réécriture on peut trouver une façon de
le rendre un peu plus lisible mais je
précise que ça ça amène bien un verrou
sur le niveau de dépenses 50% des 60% de
progression et que ce verrou là il sera
plus important que la porte d'entrée et
que le sujet c'est pas est-ce que vous
perdez de la capacité d'autofinancement
c'est quel est le delta entre la
progression de vos recettes et la
progression de vos dépenses d'énergie ça
c'est le bon critère et il faut pas
créer une prime à la mauvaise gestion je
peux pas aller beaucoup plus loin sur le
filet de sécurité parce que je viens de
vous donner
ma pensée la plus complète j'en profite
pour finir sur l'amortisseur
bon
c'est hyper complexe
c'est hyper complexe parce que si je
devais faire un schéma
quand une collectivité se retrouve avec
disons 100 mégawatts de consommation
elle a d'abord la moitié de sa
consommation qui va être couverte par la
reine un prix fixe
ça c'est général c'est la moitié ensuite
j'ai la deuxième moitié la deuxième
moitié on explique désormais que cette
deuxième moitié
si vous êtes au-delà de 325 euros du
mégawattheure et en dessous du 800
50% de ce delta est pris en charge par
l'État sauf que comme il y a la moitié
qui est en arène
si vous êtes à 325 ça veut dire qu'en
fait votre prix c'est moitié 325 moitié
42 et donc que c'est facilement 180 donc
il y a des gens qui pensent alors qu'ils
sont à 200 qui ne vont pas être aidés
par l'État parce qu'ils regardent le 325
sans s'apercevoir qu'il est écrit en
tout petit comme devant la porte de la
banque que ça vaut pour la moitié qui
n'est pas couverte par la reine
donc on a ce petit sujet j'attire
l'attention de cette Haute Assemblée
sur le fait qu'il pourrait être
souhaitable de s'interroger sur les
conditions
de révision en cours de route de
certains contrats si le moment où on les
a signés correspond à des pics de prix
et si on a des prix qui baissent dans
les mois qui viennent parce que c'est
super d'imaginer des boucliers mais la
possibilité de renégocier une partie de
ces contrats qui permettrait à la fois
d'améliorer les finances des
collectivités et de diminuer l'ampleur
des boucliers pour être de bonne
politique et ça purée davantage sur des
besoins de compétences juridiques que de
compétences budgétaires
sur le fond vert
un j'ai vu hier tous les préfets de
France et j'ai esquissé devant eux la
base de la circulaire que certains dans
le président Richard ont espère
les deux milliards d'euros il
ils ont vocation à être souples et
faciles d'utilisation et en même temps
on veut donner quelques règles pour pas
que chaque préfet se demande comment il
gère rendu sur son territoire et on a
aujourd'hui imaginé 14 portes d'entrée
je sais que ça peut sembler complexe
mais c'est beaucoup plus simple que ça
en a l'air parce que l'idée n'est pas de
dire vous êtes obligé d'aller faire la
ligne numéro 12 c'est de dire de façon
très concrète vous avez un problème
d'érosion du trait de côte vous êtes
éligible vous avez un sujet en montagne
qui est lié au réchauffement climatique
vous êtes éligible vous voulez faire de
la rénovation de bâtiments du changement
d'éclairage public de la préservation de
la biodiversité bref les mesures qui
sont bonnes pour le climat ou la
biodiversité vous êtes éligible et les
enveloppes elles sont à titre indicatif
mais la répartition elle ne se fera pas
sur la base des thèmes mais sur la base
des territoires
autrement dit 1 ce que j'ai annoncé hier
nous allons pré notifier au préfet de
région les enveloppes pour qu'ensuite il
les répartissent par département
envoyer suffisamment vite c'est conseil
ou c'est circulaire pour que les
contacts avec les associations d'élus
puissent se prendre et que rapidement
les dépenses puissent être ensuite
couvertes et engagées
et donc on est vraiment dans cette
optique je répondrai à Cécile Kirman
dans quelques instants sur la partie qui
est sur laquelle elle m'a interrogée qui
est dire si on a des problèmes de
fonctionnement et qu'on investit moins à
quoi ça sert d'avoir des subventions
d'investissement j'y arriverai plus tard
mais je finis en tout cas sur le
dispositif du fond vert et sur sa
philosophie sur la des cils
le verdissement entre guillemets suggéré
sur quelques lignes de la décile à la
minute où nous parlons n'est pas une une
orientation une philosophie du
gouvernement il y a bien une des cils de
soutien et un fond vert qui participe à
la transition écologique
l'amorce l'année prochaine c'est
d'arriver à des budgets verts c'est pas
Bercy qui va les concevoir ce sont les
associations d'élus nous avons demandé à
l'Association des Maires l'association
de départements l'Association des
régions de France de nous suggérer que
pour être un cadre de budget vert pour
que on parle tous de la même chose et
qui est pas une commune qui se regardait
mon budget hypervaire parce qu'elle
considère que quand elle fait une route
la moitié c'est des dépenses bonnes pour
le climat parce que ça sert pour les
pistes cyclables et que celle d'à côté
considère que 100% des routes c'est des
dépenses brunes parce que ça sert à
faire passer des véhicules thermiques
donc on veut vraiment qu'on construit ça
avec elle est-ce que ça peut être demain
après-demain une occasion d'avoir un
dialogue sur comment est-ce que on
améliore notre efficacité climatique
voire on crée des liens CRPE des sites
peut-être mais à la minute où on se
parle ça n'est pas le sujet le fond vert
c'est 2023 et l'idée ce sera d'avoir le
retour sur expérience j'avoue que sur la
question de comment on associe les élus
en clair est-ce que le fond vert peut
être comme la DETR est-ce qu'on peut se
retrouver avec des associations d'élus
qui discutent des critères je suis
extrêmement partagé
on est sur une année zéro je pense qu'il
faut qu'on soit très transparent avec
les élus sur l'utilisation et ce qu'il
faut qu'on fasse une commission en amont
pour 2 milliards d'euros à distribuer en
première année dans le contexte des
finances publiques qu'on connaît je ne
suis pas certain ma religion est pas
faite vous allez avoir aussi à vous
prononcer peut-être ajouter des
amendements sur le dispositif on n'est
pas hostile à la condition que ça
n'ajoute pas une complexité dans un
dispositif où vraiment toutes les
assauts des lunes nous disent il faut
que ce soit simple et il faut que ce
soit rapide
j'arrive sur les dispositifs de
péréquation
c'est vrai le budget qui arrive est
marqué
à nouveau par des légères progressions
des dispositifs de péréquation pas par
un grand soir le contexte global des
finances publiques ne militent pas de
mon point de vue pour un mécanisme de
péréquation dont on transforme les
règles pour l'année qui arrive compte
tenu de les incertitudes qui l'entourent
j'ai lu le rapport de la Cour des
comptes
je dois vous dire mon hostilité totale à
l'idée qu'on pourrait transférer la DGF
aux intercommunalités comme ça c'est
simple c'est sans langue de bois c'est
exactement ce que je pense
on est dans un mouvement subtil où il
faut défendre l'intercommunalité mais ce
serait pas la défendre que lui
transférer la DGF ce sera en faire une
cible pour toutes les communes qui
considèrent qu'elle a déjà pris trop de
poids
je considère également pour accompagner
le mouvement que c'est une fausse bonne
idée d'expliquer qu'on serait obligé
d'avoir des projets de territoire un
projet territoire s'il est pas
volontaire s'il est pas souhaité si si
correspond pas à une ambition mais qu'on
dit vous êtes obligé d'en faire un les
gens vont se sentir obligé de faire des
tartines ou d'énumérer des choses sans
qu'il a conviction donc il y a des
vraies réflexions sur comment
par rapport à l'intercommunalité on est
capable d'accompagner des
intercommunalités de projet pour que ce
soit pas des guichets de répartition
entre commune mais faire ce constat et
aboutir à l'idée qu'il faudrait remonter
toute la DGF à l'intercousse ce serait
créer un dispositif qui serait mais qui
créerait un remède qui serait pire que
le mal donc je suis totalement opposé à
ça je n'ai parlé de cette position à
personne avant vous cet après-midi mais
comme ça au moins c'est fait c'est dit
et ça me fait du bien
[Musique]
interrogé précisément sur les évolutions
de ces montantes des GF
donc il m'a demandé de le faire sur 10
ans globalement si j'élargi un tout
petit peu mon propos
la DGF a été stable jusqu'à la dernière
année du quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy
où elle a baissé de 200 millions
ensuite le quinquennat Hollande a été
marqué par des baisses dans des ampleur
inédites par le passé et depuis puisque
c'est très exactement 10 milliards 741
millions d'euros qui ont été supprimés
pendant cette période
vu comme ça
j'adore la subtilité avec laquelle
Philippe va poser la question nous
pouvons considérer que les 320 millions
ne restaure pas totalement les sommes
qui ont été prises aux élus pendant la
période Hollande
et je me suis dit les choses comme ça
mais elles font plus que compenser la
suppression de la période Sarkozy
en étant
en étant non en étant très sérieux
parce que je pense que ce sujet
évidemment mérite de l'être l'effort qui
est fait pour l'année qui arrive
globalement quand on additionne les
différents niveaux il est sans précédent
mais par rapport à un contexte ou une
inflation qui est sans précédent aussi
le choix qui est fait c'est d'avoir des
dispositifs de soutien qui sont ciblés
là on nous a dit ce serait mieux d'avoir
des dispositifs de soutien qui soit
généralisé
je pense parce qu'il y a des
hétérogénéités notamment devant les prix
de l'énergie qui sont considérables
d'une collectivité à l'autre que le
mécanisme qui est choisi il est moins
lisible
l'AMF aurait aimé que nous rajoutions
700 millions on en met deux milliards et
demi pour lequel n'auront pas le même
niveau de remerciement mais qui sont
sans doute plus juste pour faire face à
des évolutions de tarif
l'indemnité sur la dotation
pardon la dotation pour les indemnités
des élus locaux dans les communes qui se
retrouveraient à dépasser le seuil de
deux fois le potentiel fiscal moyen à
cause de l'arrivée d'un contribuable
nouveau
je serai tenté de me remettre à la
sagesse de l'Assemblée n'ayant pas eu
l'occasion de faire une rime mais je
sais ce que ça veut dire si la sagesse
correspond à un amendement de Philippe
ça ne me choquerait pas que on corrige
des effets de bord je vous signale qui
on doit mettre un million d'euros pour
couvrir les frais de garde et
l'effectivité du dispositif des frais de
garde dans les plus petites communes de
ce pays donc si vous faites un
amendement qui prévoit que pour les plus
petites communes bon trouver la manière
de le trousser pour que
on n'est pas des faits de bord mais que
ça réponde à cet élément en assumant au
moins une période transitoire de
quelques années qui permettrait à ce
stade de mettre tout le monde d'accord
le sénateur benaroche m'a interrogé non
sans malice sur le niveau du versement
mobilité pour Aix-Marseille
pourquoi je dis non sans Matisse on a un
taux national qui dépend de votre niveau
de service
plus votre niveau de service est élevé
plus vous pouvez remonter le niveau de
du versement mobile et quand vous êtes
avec un tramway ou un métro vous avez le
droit à deux sauf Paris qui a le droit à
2,95 Benoît Payan Martin vassal mon
suggéré que Marseille puisse être
aligner sur Paris mais je m'attends si
c'est fait à ce que Lyon me suggère
d'être aligné sur Marseille puis que
Bordeaux me suggère d'être à lignée sur
Lyon et donc je ne plaide pas pour un
dispositif qui ne viserait qu'un
territoire mais je vais pas éluder la
question
je pense que l'argument des 178 millions
d'euros est un mauvais argument
pour tous ceux qui ont lu le rapport de
la Chambre régionale des comptes du 31
août ça n'est pas l'état qui a imposé
des transferts
qui privent aujourd'hui la métropole
d'une capacité à assumer une partie de
ces charges de centralité ce sont les
conditions de création de la métropole
et les accords qui ont été faits entre
le président qui l'a lancé et les
collectivités qui étaient parfois
réticents qui ont abouti à ça et on ne
peut pas
corriger un défaut de conception par un
surplus de fiscalité ou en tout cas ça
n'est pas à l'état de l'assuré
moi ça ne me choquerait pas et c'est une
réflexion personnelle à ce stade
qu'on ait une réflexion sur les fameuses
zones affaiblissement
on considérant que c'est un niveau
de contrainte qui doit qui doit
permettre aux collectivités d'augmenter
leur service de transport en commun et
qu'on pourrait imaginer demain les
territoires qui sont des zones
affaiblissions bénéficient d'une sorte
de surprime dedes qui leur permettent ou
d'aller financer des mesures
d'accessibilité sociale pour les plus
fragiles ou de généraliser des
transports en commun qui peuvent être un
bon moyen de décarboner d'éviter l'usage
de véhicules anciens et sous cette
réserve en laissant cette faculté au
territoire ça permettrait des
territoires comme Aix-Marseille en gros
au plus grandes agglomérations de France
de pouvoir être accompagné et j'ajoute
que ça pourrait convaincre des
collectivités qui sont à la marge de se
demander si elle n'aurait pas un intérêt
à conduire une politique qui serait
ambitieux sur le plan de la qualité de
l'air en disposant de moyens
complémentaires pour leur transport en
commun
j'arrive aux questions de la Richard
d'abord sur le fond vert j'ai répondu
sur le nombre de lignes j'ai répondu sur
le TRV le fait que ce soit 10 salariés
et pas dit jetp je le découvre et je
vais m'enquérir de la manière dont on
peut accompagner le dispositif sur
l'amortisseur sécurité je n'ai peut-être
pas été clair mais c'était le mieux que
je puisse faire sans paperboard
et donc je pense avoir globalement des
éléments la précédente Gatel je lui ai
dit un mot sur la C3S j'ai répondu sur
la CVE sur les contrats de Cahors sur le
filet elle m'a interrogé sur le filet de
sécurité sur les DOM-TOM la spécificité
des Outre-mer c'est que les
collectivités les entreprises et les
particuliers sont soumis au tarif
réglementés de vente d'électricité ce
qui leur permet d'avoir un dispositif de
protection un avantage plus élevé que ce
qui existe en métropole avec dans un
certain nombre de domaines une fiscalité
réduite qui permet de compenser la
charte de la vie et les difficultés qui
peuvent exister par ailleurs
ensuite
une question très précise sur les
communes nouvelles
d'abord le covid a éclipsé une loi qui
avait été votée ici et qui crée les
communes communautés madame la
Présidente Gatel qui était votre œuvre
mais qui finalement aurait pu entrer en
vigueur au moment où les mères se sont
trouvés avec davantage de préoccupations
sanitaires
et dans les préconisations du rapport de
la Cour des comptes il y a le fait de
refaire la pubicité de ces communes
communautés je glisse ça au passage
je tiens à vous dire que dans le cadre
du 49-3 un amendement déposé par le
groupe liote qui maintient la dpel en
cas de fusion
de communes pour créer une commune
nouvelle a été maintenue dans la version
du PLF qui vous sera transmise et donc
il y a bien une préservation une
sanctuarisation de cet avantage
concernant les communes nouvelles qui
vous est proposée qui correspond je
pense à vos attentes
j'ai entendu avec beaucoup d'attention
d'intervention de Cécile Karman pour
laquelle j'ai une tendresse particulière
pour avoir été le coût Benjamin de cette
assemblée avec elle ou plus exactement
pour avoir cru pendant quelques minutes
que je serai le benjamin du Sénat avant
de découvrir l'élection de Cécile
tukerman
et un certain soir de 2011 j'ai entendu
donc ce qu'elle dit sur la nécessité de
soutenir les investissements je souhaite
dire la chose suivante
toute la difficulté vous avez parlé de
transition écologique c'est précisément
comment
on soutient des investissements qui nous
évitent de nous retrouver avec des
puissants font en matière de
fonctionnement
et j'annonce à cette commission notre
volonté de creuser de manière
extrêmement forte
un dispositif de modification du code de
la commande publique pour sortir
de la vision binaire quels sont les
niveaux de fiscalité pardon quels sont
les niveaux de dépenses publiques qu'il
faut qu'on ajoute pour faire en sorte de
pouvoir accélérer la transition
écologique on est aujourd'hui contraint
et taille collectivités territoriale en
particulier par un article du code de la
commande publique qui nous empêche
de passer des contrats de performance
rémunérés sur les économies qui arrivent
si demain nous modifions cette article
là nous pourrions libérer et des
budgétiser si j'ose dire aussi bien de
l'État que des collectivités locales des
masses considérables d'investissement la
plus importante étant par exemple pour
les réseaux d'éclairage public parce que
si demain vous pouvez passer un contrat
qui consiste à dire je ne verse rien
mais pendant la durée du contrat je
continue de payer ce qu'est le montant
annuel de ma facture mais en échange
vous passez tout en LED quand vous
pensez qu'on a 10 millions de
lampadaires qui en a 15% qui sont en
l'aide et que le passage en l'aide c'est
entre 40 et 50% de baisse sont comptés
les dispositifs de déduction de présence
et que c'est 40% en moyenne des dépenses
d'électricité des communes ce sont des
marches qui sont considérables et sur
lequel il faut qu'on trouve des leviers
qui ne sont pas que de la dépense
publique on a des exemples à prendre sur
l'Allemagne où ils savent bien des
budgétisés tout en jouant ensuite les
élèves modèles
l'électricien allemand qui sont en train
de nationaliser c'est l'orchestre des
dépôts qui le rachètent se sont pas les
fonds du PLF qui servent
pour procéder à l'opération et on a le
droit d'être sur ces sujets imaginatifs
quand il s'agit de préserver la planète
et de pas creuser les trous j'ai dit au
sénateur Richards que j'en pensais et il
me reste une un seul sujet qui est
l'interpellation Didier Marie dont
j'adorais qu'elle soit totalement vrai
parce que la suggestion qui consiste à
dire il y a 30,9 milliards qui sont
récupérables c'est finalement bien plus
que les 12 dont on a besoin avec le
delta on rajoute 700 millions sur la DGF
on multiplie par deux le filet on crée
des dispositifs ce serait fabuleux sauf
que c'est 30,9 sont déjà très largement
gagés mais ça ne se voit pas
le bouclier tarifaire pour les
collectivités c'est 46 milliards d'euros
de dépenses et 30,9 milliards d'euros de
recettes en fait
la rente des énergies renouvelables
telles que c'est considérés c'est-à-dire
le sur-profit de ces énergies
renouvelables c'est ce qui nous permet
de financer les deux tiers du bouclier
tarifaire pour les particuliers et pour
les structures de moins de 10 salariés
et donc sur cette somme nous assumons un
effort budgétaire de près de 16
milliards d'euros qui figurent dans le
PLF et on complète avec les 12 milliards
qui sont l'addition de l'amortisseur
électricité du guichet pour les très
grandes entreprises du filet de sécurité
pour les collectivités territoriales à
hauteur de 12 milliards qui sont assurés
par les 3 milliards du fond Ukraine et
par les 7 milliards du dispositif de
rente européenne
qui s'applique non pas sur les énergies
renouvelables mais en particulier sur
les surprofits qui sont liées au gaz et
qui s'appuie sur le dispositif européen
le delta étant des crédits budgétaires
qui sont déjà qui sont déjà inscrits
donc malheureusement il n'y a pas de rab
et cette somme elle est en face du
bouclier tarifaire
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs les quelques réponses que je
pouvais vous faire en vous remerciant de
la précision de vos questions et en
espérant que mes réponses vous auront
pour la plupart satisfaite en attendant
d'avoir sans doute l'occasion d'y
répondre dans l'hémicycle quand nous
passerons à la suite
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
explications et donc nous levons la
séance pour quelques minutes merci